much better we have a new ant-man
trailer it looks a lot better than that
first trailer when I talked about the
first trailer in a video I was like I
mean it looks enjoyable enough I guess
but it's pretty run-of-the-mill a guy
gets a second chance and becomes a hero
and you know to stop bad guys and
this trailer is pretty much the same
premise but they execute it in a way
where you're like no that looks good
it's just Paul Rudd using this power to
the suit to control ants you know see
where the ants stand up the penny and
spin and spinning a penny it's hard just
to do with one hand to get ants to do it
I can imagine it's difficult and it does
have the humor that you want to see in a
movie like this because you don't want
it to be to steer by God's movie called
ant-man about a guy who controls ants if
it takes itself too seriously I'm gonna
walk out that movie going they just
didn't know where they should have gone
with that cuz they were Evangeline Lilly
it's like alright you need to learn how
to punch it's like alright show me how
to produce she just punches him in the
face I was like that's awesome cuz
that's what I would do I really showed
me how to punch if she decked me I'd be
like let's back please don't do that
again but respect I love you were like
that in a movie like this the Marvel
Cinematic Universe generally speaking is
known as a franchise it's an action
franchise that has humor in it and
there's something very Iron Man 1
feeling about this trailer credit I love
Iron Man 1 so I'm pretty much gonna
compare any Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie that I really like the tone of the
Iron Man 1 because I liked it so much
but so surprising to me there is
something very Iron Man 1 about this a
guy who gets a suit and then someone
else the bad guy gets another suit and
those two suits have to fight not a bad
thing I think that's great because I did
not get the Iron Man 1 vibe from the
first ant-man trailer I kind of got the
alright vibe from that trailer and I
loved that scene where Evangeline Lulu's
like you have a lot of power in the suit
you know you're super strong
she doesn't flip up on the gun and run
across the gun jump through the bullet
hole in the window turn big and flip the
guy around they're reminded me of that
comic-con footage we got where he pretty
much does the same thing it's ant-man
he's running and he turns small and runs
up a gun and then flips the guy around
by his tie at Comic Con test footage
pretty much doing right by fan and the
bad guy looks cool in this movie we
didn't get a view of any villains in the
first trailer this one's like alright he
throws down with ant-man it looks
awesome and at the point where they're
all fighting and he's shooting his
lasers at ant-man
Ant Man coming at him I was like this
all takes place at a very small world to
us in the trailer addresses the most
hilarious way possible they're fighting
about looks like a little kids room but
it's so epic looking cuz they're all
small and they flip around on the - to
train he gets down in the tree it's
coming Yellowjackets like No
it's gonna hit these little trainset and
it just goes I just cracked me a pose
like that's what that's exactly what I
was thinking but I loved that guy's in
the end I love this trailer I am so
thrilled to say ant-man looks good
because like I said the first trailer I
was like and whatever we have a lot of
other Marvel movies gonna be good sure
this is an improvement
breck I so the new ant-man trailer have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]